simplifica xy elevado a la potencia
menos 2 que multiplica a 2x cuadrada
sobre ye cuadrada todo esto elevado a la
cuarta potencia
veamos que podemos hacer con esto
hagamos primero esta parte para esto
vamos a utilizar algo que ya sabemos que
si tenemos x sobre y elevado a la
potencia n esto es igual a x a la n
sobre i a la n apliquemos eso a esta
expresión aquí tenemos dos x cuadradas
sobre ye cuadrada elevado a la cuarta
potencia aplicando esa propiedad tenemos
2x cuadrada elevado a la cuarta sobre ye
cuadrada también elevado a la cuarta
potencia aún tenemos aquí x por ye
elevado a la menos 2 voy a empezar a
simplificar esta expresión usando la
siguiente propiedad si tenemos x porque
elevado a la n esto equivale a tomar
cada uno de estos factores elevarlos a
la n y luego multiplicarlos así que esto
es igual a x a la n porque a la n de
hecho si realizas esta operación de
multiplicar x por n veces
asimismo puedes recomendar los términos
para tener x x sí mismo n veces y
multiplicado por sí mismo n veces
entonces aplicando esta propiedad a x
porque elevado a la menos 2 eso va a ser
exactamente igual a x a la menos dos
porque a la menos 2 y ahora que podemos
simplificar bien podemos usar esta
propiedad de nueva cuenta aquí donde
tenemos 2x cuadrada elevado a la cuarta
esto es equivalente entonces a 2 elevado
a la cuarta 2 elevado a la cuarta que
multiplica a x cuadrada elevado a la
cuarta y eso dividido entre de cuadrada
elevado a la cuarta para esto vamos a
usar una propiedad distinta vamos a usar
la propiedad que dice que si tengo x
elevado a la potencia n y eso elevado a
la potencia m esto es igual a x elevado
a la potencia n por m así es que aquí he
elevado al cuadrado y elevado a la
cuarta es lo mismo que tener y elevado a
la 2 x 4 es decir es igual a elevado a
la octava potencia y aquí está
x elevado al menos 2 por elevado al
menos 2 para esto veamos qué significa x
elevado a menos 2 y elevado a la menos 2
x elevado a la menos 2 es igual a 1
sobre x cuadrada y elevado a menos 2 es
igual a 1 sobre ye cuadrada así es que
este término se convierte en así es que
este término que está multiplicando aquí
es 1 sobre x cuadrada por 1 sobre ye
cuadrada que también podemos escribir
como 1 sobre x cuadrada y cuadrada y
ahora lo último que vamos a hacer
no creo que no creo que hay un par de
cosas más que hay que hacer vamos a
resolver aquí x cuadrada elevado a la
cuarta
vamos a usar esta propiedad x cuadrada
elevado a la cuarta esto va a ser igual
x a la 2 x 4 es decir esto de aquí
equivale a x a la octava esto es
exactamente igual a x elevado a la
octava potencia y este 2 elevado a la
cuarta que tenemos aquí es 2 al cubo es
8 8 por 2 16 esto equivale a 16 y ahora
voy a hacer este producto multiplico
numerador por numerador y denominador
por denominador para obtener 1 por 16 16
que multiplica a x al octava y todo eso
dividido entre aquí tenemos x cuadrada
eso dividido entre x cuadrada por de
cuadrada x ya la octava aquí podemos
usar esta propiedad y encuadrada por ya
la octava esto es igual al elevado a la
2 + 8 y elevado a la 28 que es igual a
ye elevado a la décima potencia si es
que esto es ya elevado a la décima
potencia y casi hemos terminado nos
falta simplificar una cosa más
aquí tenemos x a la octava sobre x
cuadrada y sabemos aquí voy a escribir
la propiedad en general
si tenemos x a la m sobre x a la n esto
es igual a x a la m - n
así es que aquí que tenemos x a la
octava sobre x cuadrada esto es igual a
x a la 8 menos 2 y esto es igual a x a
lasexta así es que finalmente nuestra
expresión simplificada es igual a 16 que
multiplica a x a lasexta
16 x x a la sexta dividido entre que
elevado a la décima potencia llega a la
décima y así hemos terminado